how you doing sir I'm doing I'm doing
wonderfully a little jet lag but uh that
never hurt anybody uh so I'm actually
curious I'm a fan of you directing
outside of Star Wars and feature films
so I'm curious are you developing
anything to direct uh outside of Star
Wars I'm working on on uh I'm working on
other things but not uh any films to
speak of at this time
got it that's outside of Star Wars yeah
uh I was told I can only ask one
question is that the end that was the
one you used it on I wanted to see if
you were making another movie
so my my hands are I'll answer that more
thoroughly and then give me that I
there's so much work that goes into
there's so much energy that goes into
making a show especially when you're
writing as much as I am on it but then
also to be you know to be producing and
working with other filmmakers so it this
is one of those careers where it's very
hard uh to
you're already fully engaged I also work
on you ever seen prehistoric planet on
on Apple TV plus so I'm very fortunate
that my time is completely uh is
completely uh uh encompassed with with
these these shows that I'm working on
now I'll ask you something very fast
what do you think fans are going to be
what do you think the fan reaction or
what do you think they'll be thinking
when episode 8 ends of the Mandalorian
season three what a good way to ask that
question uh hopefully they'll feel
um satisfied
they'll feel
um resolved and they'll also feel a
little surprised